[Applause]
uh Mr President thank you
at the end of such a momentous event
the word thank you seems kind of
inadequate but for all the Millions
whose lives will be saved
for the communities where life will be
transformed thank you so thank you
President Biden for your ads
what up internet I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's September 30th
2022. we're live streaming on
rumbleblaze TV and YouTube subscribe if
you have not particularly over there on
Rumble rumble.com Reuben report so you
will see all of our videos with no
algorithmic manipulation thank you uh
okay obviously a lot I want to talk
about today normally we do our Friday
Roundtable shows but because we had a
short week uh I just wanted to go solo
this week obviously with everything else
going on uh in terms of the hurricane
that has just ravaged Southwest Florida
which now uh yesterday it had turned
into a tropical storm apparently it's a
hurricane now and it's hitting South
Carolina as we speak I wanted to just
recap a little bit about what's going on
here in Florida and how you can help how
I'm going to try to help and then I want
to get into a couple other things that
are happening internationally at the
moment there was a question in our show
yesterday from locals about the
nordstream pipeline that blew up and I
promise to get you some more information
on that so we did a deep dive this
morning so we'll talk about that and
also Kamala Harris the wizard the vice
president the genius the woman who knows
that Russia big and Ukraine small she's
in uh South Korea although she thinks
she's in North Korea and we'll get to
that and much more uh most importantly
though I do want to get you caught up on
a couple things going on here in Florida
you know I mentioned to you guys
yesterday that my folks have a little
condo in Sanibel Island and Governor
DeSantis yesterday was giving a press
conference that we're going to show you
a little bit more in a moment where he
said that the storm surge in Sanibel
Island which is a barrier reef Island
Southwest Florida he said was biblical I
mean the island has absolutely been
decimated this is a place I've been
going literally since I was born for 46
years at this point multiple times a
year a place that I just absolutely
adore and love that my whole family
loves this is where we do all of our
family vacation and all of that sort of
stuff
so I'm very sad about Sanibel we finally
did get some images and it's actually
it's incredible what what I saw down
there so they showed my parents whole uh
complex and there's about I don't know
18 or 20 apartment you know units
they're all separated each one has four
condos in them every single one is
basically blown apart and just the roofs
destroyed massive damage Windows broken
everything except my parents building
it's it's crazy and the reason for that
I think is because a couple years ago
the place itself was struck by lightning
and burned down that was something we
had to deal with a couple years back and
it was rebuilt so because it was rebuilt
it was newer and stronger maybe had more
hurricane resistant beams all sorts of
stuff maybe the windows were better I
don't even know exactly but it is the
one that's sort of standing in their
Community it's crazy it could be
destroyed inside there could be massive
water damage and everything else but
that was like a glimmer of good news
that that my family got pose but I'm
going to do everything I can to help the
island and man there's a lot of work to
happen here in Florida but we have the
right people uh in charge so I want to
start today with a video of the first
lady of Florida Casey DeSantis and she
basically is leading the fundraising
efforts to get people to donate to fix
this state as quickly as possible here's
Casey DeSantis yesterday
say on behalf of half of it myself
everyone here who's working at the
Emergency Operations Center all of the
men and women who have not left since
it's a disaster began to all of those
people across the state our First
Responders I want to say thank you
because the people across the state and
the country have stepped up big to
support our Florida disaster fund so far
in less than 24 hours since we launched
the fund we've raised 1.6 million
dollars I am in constant contact with
two folks one the people who volunteer
Florida to pledge that we are going to
remove any red tape and bureaucracy from
getting those funds deployed to the
people who need them immediately and
then also we're working with a lot of
businesses across the state to continue
to build upon that but thank you to the
people across this country and this
state for stepping up stepping up to
help wonderful people who are in need
again there's a couple of ways that if
you want to continue to donate you can
go to
floridadisasterfund.org or you can also
text disaster to
20222 but on behalf of so many wonderful
people thank you for stepping up and
please continue to do so
okay so I just wanted to show you that
because I'm just so as you know I'm
proud and honored to be a Floridian but
in times like this when there's real
crisis it's not just the the average
day-to-day political fight the fact that
we have a governor who is so competent
and cares and is doing everything
possible and he's married to a first
lady who is stepping in to the to the
battle right now to raise funds and make
sure that they get to the right people
and to the right places it's just
fantastic I'm also thrilled to tell you
guys that uh Rumble and local so Rumble
of course was a Canadian company that
has moved to Sarasota Florida Sarasota
got hit not as bad as sort of Hardcore
Southwest Florida but it is on the west
coast of Florida Rumble is in Sarasota
locals is here in Miami Rumble and
locals have donated a hundred thousand
dollars towards relief efforts so I'm
thrilled to be part of that I'm going to
do some other stuff on the side and just
as a reminder you can text disaster to
20222
or you can go to
volunteerflorida.org right now and you
can see you can volunteer you can donate
you can get some more information and uh
as I said yesterday and as I'll probably
say for a while as much as we cover this
Florida's got a lot of work to do I have
no doubt it will rebuild they will
figure out you know can these Barrier
Islands exist with people on them and do
they have to change things how much
damage is actually there does every
building have to be on stilts I mean all
of the stuff all of the stuff but I will
also reiterate that as Floridians chip
in with money and services and goods and
all of those things which we're seeing
all over the state I mean it's really
fantastic you know we are giving crazy
amounts of money to Ukraine right now
and it's like I don't know could a
couple of those billion be spent down
here in Florida
probably and could we get that bridge
that Sanibel Causeway fixed if the Army
Corps of Engineers wanted to do it could
they get it fixed in probably like a
month yeah they probably could but we
seem to be spending a lot of money on
things across the world that nobody's
exactly sure what we're doing we'll
actually talk more about that in just a
moment so anyway
the theme today beyond the we'll just
put the Florida stuff aside for a moment
and I also just want to say that I
really appreciate all your your good
wishes and you know if I was getting my
email and my phone was blowing up people
looking out for us obviously we're good
to go here in Miami so it's all good but
the theme today really is what's going
on sort of internationally at the moment
and how that's connected to our domestic
politics so as I said Kamala Harris in
South Korea and she just really botched
it Biden given speeches doesn't know
where he is he saw the called open and
then I do want to talk about the
Nordstrom Pipeline and we'll wrap it up
by going right back to the beginning
about competency and what's going on
again here in Florida so that is the
plan for today and before we get to it
let me talk to you guys about real
estate agents I trust you guys know that
selling a home or buying a home is one
of the most stressful things you can do
and it can be 10 times worse if you're
not working with the right agent usually
our homes are our biggest investment
which of course is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why I
recommend real estate agents I trust
they work with only the best agents in
every Market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their Network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
Pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team makes the introduction
and then follows you through the buying
or selling process to make sure that
you're satisfied the agents they work
with have long track records and are the
best sellers in their field they're part
of this audience they share your values
and they're almost anywhere you want to
go just head on over to
realestateagents.itrust.com today give
them some basic info they'll contact you
to make an introduction to a preferred
agent in your town you will move
possibly to the free state of Florida
help us rebuild this place and live
happily ever after okay so Kamala Harris
our vice president who as you guys know
was polling at zero that's zero in her
own party when Joe Biden or the people
in charge of Joe Biden plucked her to be
the vice president she is in South Korea
the problem is she doesn't know where
she is exactly she went to the
demilitarized zone it's known as the DMZ
which is basically between North Korea
and South Korea uh here's just a little
bite from the daily wire this is a day
before she arrived and then we'll show
you some video Harris will travel to the
demilitarized zone between North Korea
and South Korea Thursday where she will
tour sites at the DMZ meet with service
members and receive an operational
briefing from U.S commanders the White
House confirmed the vice president's
scheduled trip to the DMZ will follow
her Tuesday meeting with South Korean
prime minister Han duks who your visit
to the DMZ and Seoul will be very
symbolic demonstrations of your strong
commitments to the security and peace to
the Korean Peninsula and we are working
with you and U.S in dealing with North
Korea on told Harris at the bilateral
meeting okay pretty good South Korea is
an ally of ours North Korea obviously is
is a rogue State and has nukes and it's
a big issue and you may remember that
President Trump met with the leader of
North Korea and people said it was all
very evil and blah blah blah
we didn't get any wars out of it he was
trying to do a little something anyway
uh Kamala went to South Korea and to the
demilitarized zone and totally botched
the entire thing listen closely so the
United States
shares a very important relationship
which is an alliance with the Republic
of North Korea
and it is an alliance that is strong and
enduring
did you catch that people I think we
have to show it again just in case they
weren't listening closely listen to
Kamala so the United States
shares a very important relationship
which is an alliance with the Republic
of North Korea
and
it is an alliance that is strong and
enduring
I did not know that weird wild stuff we
share an alliance with North Korea
those are the bad guys in case you guys
are paying attention uh no we have an
alliance with South Korea we don't like
North Korea we don't really have any
diplomatic relations with them we don't
really talk to them Trump tried to do a
little something everyone freaked out
that he was talking to Asian Hitler I
mean it's but it's just look I get it
it's a verbal gaffe but at some point
between Biden never knowing where he is
shaking hands with the air being
confused and being unable to read a
teleprompter and then this woman with
her crazy circular logic and the verbal
gaps and clearly having no idea what
she's doing and being and being so over
her head and all this maybe it's
starting to be a problem do you think
maybe the South Koreans when they hear
that are like like this guy's got nukes
uh we're in trouble people uh here's
some video of her at the DMZ and she's
just blown away by what's going on over
there
come on
[Music]
and it's so cool it's it's 50 meters
away that's it
and it's so close it's 50 meters away
just everything her holding the
binoculars my whole guy everyone in here
was laughing at that it's just like what
she just sounds so stupid like like she
has no idea they threw her there I get
it they put her on a plane and they put
her there but she just doesn't
understand anything about the nature of
the geopolitical situation between South
Korea and North Korea she just knows
nothing about it and here she is talking
to a couple servicemen who are stationed
at the DMZ listen to the way she talks
to them about telescopes
the world
so we invested in this telescope
and the images just came there and they
show us three billionaires in the back
to the beginning to all these gowns it's
the most humbling thing you've ever seen
so when we think we've seen everything
laughs
okay
God these poor Guys these are serious
people with a serious job where like you
know you're on a hair trigger all day
long if someone tries to cross that
demilitarized zone these countries you
know I don't know if they technically
are at a state of war in a technical
definition of War but like anything
could happen at any given moment with
this Rogue State sitting on your border
and then they have to listen to this
woman babbling talking she talks to
everyone like they're in second grade
and if you were in second grade it would
still be insulting to your intelligence
listening to her but anyway she goes to
South Korea she talks about our alliance
our magical alliance with North Korea
but before that was something really
really nuts uh that happened that is
international Mass should be massive
international news because this is this
is absolutely huge with the backdrop of
what's going on with Russia and Ukraine
but the Nord stream pipeline blew up in
a couple spots now I want to give you
just like a basic definition or basic
explanation of what the nordstream
pipeline is first so just like we're
doing nordstream 101 because I know that
you know the mainstream media doesn't
cover this stuff properly so people just
don't even know what anything is so the
Nordstrom pipeline is an undersea
pipeline which stretches 700
745 miles under the Baltic Sea from the
Russian Coast near Saint Petersburg to
the north to Northeastern Germany it
opened it opened in two thousand 11 and
can send a maximum of 170 million cubic
meters of gas per day from Russia to
Germany okay so the basic part of this
thing is it's a really long pipeline
Russia has natural gas Germany does not
they import all of this gas the winter
is coming they're going to need heat and
then suddenly in at least four sections
uh it appears that the Nordstrom
pipeline has blown up so we've got some
more info here from the daily wire three
lines in the nordstream natural gas
pipeline system saw unprecedented damage
on Monday weeks after the CIA warned
Germany of possible attacks today we
faced an act of sabotage polish prime
minister Moto murawicki said we don't
know all the details of what happened
but we clearly see that it's an act of
sabotage related to The Next Step of
escalation in the situation in Ukraine
when asked about the possibility of
sabotage kremlin's spokesman Dimitri
peskov told reporters that no option can
be ruled out at the moment okay
so now a couple so there in that article
they referenced uh three places of
sabotage there's actually a fourth now
it is unclear who did this we're seeing
all the sort of swamp creatures saying
that maybe Russia did it to itself that
they blew it up themselves to escalate
the war like just like a whole bunch of
craziness uh but yes there is video uh
that there is now a fourth leak right
now
the Swedish Coast Guard on Thursday said
it's discovered a fourth unexplained gas
leak in the undersea nordstream
pipelines linking Russia to Europe and
as gas Rose to the surface allegations
of sabotage flew between Brussels Moscow
and Washington
the European Union is investigating the
cause of the leaks in the Nordstrom one
and two pipelines under the Baltic Sea
and has said it suspects sabotage to
which it promised a quote robust and
United response but it has not said who
is to blame
okay so it has not said who is to blame
now you may be wondering why is this
important like okay there's gas
pipelines all over Europe and people get
resources from other countries and all
of those things the reason that it's
deeply important is because with the
backdrop of everything going on with the
Russian invasion in Ukraine you know
you're seeing all of these people saying
oh Russia's starting to lose it's not
working out well they're you know
Putin's gonna backtrack all this stuff
it's like I'm not so sure that Putin has
nukes the guy with the bigger weapons uh
usually does not lose so now this
pipeline that is a major
export to Germany to Western nations in
Europe has blown up in four parts did
they blow it up themselves well then
there's some strange video that's come
out over the last couple months here is
uh secretary Tony blinken uh back in
January uh kind of explaining what's
going on with the Nordstrom Pipeline and
The Leverage situation there this
pipeline does not have gas flowing
through it at present
and if Russia renews its aggression
toward Ukraine it would certainly be
difficult to see uh
gas flowing through it in the future
so some may see Nordstrom too as
leverage that Russia can use against
Europe in fact
it's leverage for Europe to use against
Russia
uh did you catch that so that's back in
January and basically he's saying uh you
know we have some leverage over you
Russia because if we don't like how this
war thing's working out or if you don't
pull out of Ukraine we he's in essence
saying we could blow this freaking thing
up because this is a cash cow for Russia
and we will want to harm you and hamper
you however we possibly can and then
this video came out this is President
Joe Biden back in January basically
making a threat and it sort of seems
like it's come true
let me answer this first question first
if Germany if uh if Russia invades uh
that means tanks or troops crossing the
uh the the border of Ukraine again then
uh there will be uh we there will be no
longer on North stream too we we will
bring it into it
so how will you do that
exactly since the project and control of
the project is within Germany's control
we will I promise you we'll be able to
do it
you get what's going on here I mean this
is really nuts and this is where it's so
disappointing that we don't have a
mainstream media that will honestly
assess these issues and go back to
videos this is why we do the show the
way we do it and why I always jump to
old clips and everything because you
have to start looking at the past to
understand the future or certainly
understand the present right so Biden is
saying this is back in January he's
saying if Russia goes into Ukraine and
we know Russia has gone into Ukraine
we're going to end the pipeline then
suddenly this past Monday the pipeline
blows up in four spots and now we've got
our usual swamp creature saying Russia
blew up its own pipeline like
this war or whatever this thing is it's
hard to even call it a war because we're
not in a declared war of course and
we're just sending them all sorts of
money and we're arming everybody and all
that stuff but this this war that is
happening uh this very sort of ephemeral
War that's going on throughout the world
right now that's connecting United
States and Europe and all of these all
of these places across the globe
um it does seem like it's heating up and
did we just blow up this Pipeline and if
we did uh is Russia going to declare war
on us I mean it all sounds nuts but here
we are I suppose so what is Biden's uh
reaction now that this is happening well
he was at a FEMA station uh talking
about Florida and how the federal
government can help and as I said
yesterday
Biden may not be my guy I may think he's
incompetent I don't think he's in charge
or anything else but I hope he will do
the right thing here and get whatever
federal funds need to get to Florida so
mostly people are asking about that then
he got asked about what's going on with
the Nordstrom pipeline
Russia responsible rupture of the north
stream pipeline
let's stick with this okay
there's a lot of important in National
issues but we're here to talk about
America
okay so he doesn't want to answer
questions and there's probably reasons I
I actually don't want to speculate too
much but it is possible that it's a
little bit of plausible deniability
either he doesn't know exactly what we
did or he just doesn't want to talk
about it until he doesn't get caught in
a lie but it does sort of feel like
somebody blew the thing up and it
probably wasn't Russia well literally
one second after that video uh where he
did not answer a question then he did
something that was much more in line
with the Joe Biden we've all come to
know okay thank you thank you Mr
President
foreign
God help us all okay so uh there's Biden
doesn't know where he is always
wandering off very confused so be it at
least he must have functional competent
people around him right here's noted
black lesbian Karin Jean-Pierre uh
talking about Nordstrom except she
thinks it's Nordstroms so
I'm here to say this what what we see
Russia's doing and we've been very clear
about this is that they're using energy
they're weaponizing energy and it's
choosing to to one of the things that
has been out there the shutdown the
pipeline of Nordstrom one
Nordstrom's going down people Nordstrom
Rack you're not going to get those
half-price jackets okay where you think
you're going to get well your uh your
nice shirts and they often have wallets
there some perfume a little bit cheaper
that sort of thing you're not gonna get
it because Russia and the energy or
something
kind of put together a nice little
package for us on this Nordstrom
situation one of the things that has
been out there that shut down the
pipeline of Nordstrom one
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that's some fine work there Connor
you're getting extra guacamole today uh
okay so now we're in this situation
where as you guys know since well really
since Joe Biden took office uh but
really escalated in the last like six
months you know gas prices have gone
crazy they've now dropped a tiny bit a
tiny bit which has the whole
Administration saying see gas prices are
going down and it's always like yes
they're going down a tiny bit because
thanks to your incompetence and
everything you've done to the economy
they went up so high and now they're
going down a tiny bit and you want
credit for that
um but Biden knows that there's about to
be another spike in gas prices right
this we are in an interconnected world
if a massive pipeline blows up that's
sending energy to Germany uh then it's
going to affect prices here it's just
how it is right and we seem to be
playing into every one of Putin's moves
so he wants to make sure that the blame
doesn't go on him for this Nordstrom
I did it for this Nordstrom situation uh
so he wants to blame oil and gas
Executives uh because of the hurricane
you know they're going to price gouge
you I also want to say again to the oil
and gas Executives do not do not do not
use this storm as an excuse to raise
gasoline prices or gouge the American
public the price of oil has dropped in
recent weeks the price of gas should be
going down as rapidly as not
my experts inform me the production of
only about 160 000 barrels a day has
been impacted by this storm that's less
than two percent of our country's daily
production it's small and temporary
impact on oil production provides no
excuse no excuse for price increases at
the pump period if a gas station
companies try to use this storm to raise
prices I'm going to ask I'm going to ask
officials to look into whether or not
price gouging is going on it's just so
incredible because he is the price
gouger in Chief he is the one that has
caused inflation with crazy spending and
the inflation reduction act and all of
these things and all of our bad policies
instead of drilling here and now he
knows because of this war that gas
prices are rising because of whoever
blew up the Nordstrom pipeline gas
prices are going to rise and who is he
threatening he's threatening the gas
companies and he's threatening them mom
and pop shops that are your local gas
station that's who he's threading he is
the gouger in Chief and he's going to
look into them it's like do you think
that these people I can tell you very
clearly here in Florida with this
disaster going on there are not gas
station owners who are like yes this is
my chance to make all the money I can no
there really aren't I have seen so many
people chipping in across the board
everywhere now it's not to say that
there aren't some outlier cases and of
course whenever there's natural
disasters you're going to get some
looting you're going to get some people
with price gouging of course you're
going to always get that it's part of
the human condition whether we like it
or not right there's always people who
will take advantage of a bad situation
but this clown I mean he and also the
way he's reading and it's like you just
know he doesn't even know what he's
saying but it has nothing prices have
nothing to do with him inflation has
nothing to do with him all of it has
nothing to do with him it's always it's
the mean oil companies it's those bad
Republicans and just awful well okay
want to bring you home on a positive
note so from Joe Biden sort of
incompetent gouger in Chief there are
some virtuous leaders in this country
there are some people trying to take
care of their people and do the right
thing and do it for the right reasons
and not just endlessly accumulate power
and take from some and give to others
yeah we're back in Florida here is
Governor Ron DeSantis making a surprise
visit to the hurricane relief
headquarters there's gonna be a lot of
people that need help and you guys have
been on the front lines of doing that so
I just want to say thank you we'll be
back uh we'll be back tomorrow if I'll
be back you know every day for a while
and so we're here to help and when you
guys need anything he knows could call
all these other people know just give us
a call and I'll make sure Kevin gets it
done so thanks everybody appreciate it
people working hard and hearing from the
top exec hey we appreciate you we're
going to be here for you we're going to
make sure we can do everything that we
can do that's what it's all about that's
what it's all about uh Governor DeSantis
later he's given press conference after
press conference after press conference
the guy's bouncing all over the state
he's doing everything he possibly can uh
he talked about the severity of the
storm uh and uh particularly on Sanibel
which as I've discussed is very close to
my heart
in our area Sanibel Island Fort Myers
Beach the images are devastating and we
know that from our local agencies that
there have been confirmed deaths we
don't know exactly how many what have
you heard from the local agencies about
the scope of the tragedy in that sense
will Sanibel is destruction I mean this
is I mean for those of you haven't been
beautiful it's a beautiful place a
really neat community and it got hit
with really biblical storm surge most of
what's being done to assist is is air
operation since you can't get there on
the ground I think Kevin will probably
have more more boats uh head over there
as well but the important thing is I was
able to speak to the mayor this morning
and and she and her key staff did
evacuate and so they've been operating
off more of the Mainland in Lee County
and and many people did leave Sanibel
and they did heed the call which is good
obviously I think you know it's a very
seasonal Community we're not quite in
the High season yet but I think she made
the point hey it's Florida more people
want to be here year round now so you do
have a contingent of people that stay
there over the summer but we're
committed to restoring the
infrastructure as needed that is not
going to be an overnight task that is
going to be something that is going to
require a lot a lot of love and care
it's going to require a lot of resources
guys I know that listening to
politicians talk during natural
disasters is not like the most
entertaining thing right there's a limit
for all of us to do it I'm doing cardio
every morning I've been watching these
press conferences but I know everyone
has a limit and if you're not in Florida
it doesn't mean as much to you perhaps
and
all of that kind of stuff I really am
showing you that in this case more to
just juxtapose it with what's going on
with our our federal leaders right like
Kamala not knowing who's our alliance in
in North Korea and South Korea and Joe
Biden not even knowing really where he
is and blaming everyone else for all of
this uh Governor DeSantis also is
calling for volunteers here in Florida
I'm gonna by the way if anyone's
watching this if you have venues or
anything in Southwest Florida that I
will go I'll do shows at obviously for
free and I'll throw in money myself but
any any way that I can help please
contact us the best way to get us is
through local so reubenreport.locals.com
and I will do everything that I possibly
can but Governor is directly calling for
volunteers to help out for those who
want to come volunteer we have an
official volunteer portal at volunteer
Florida and that's at
www.volunteerflorida.org
www.volunteerflorida.org and you can
look to see of the volunteer opportunity
yeah I've been looking in our locals
community and I know a bunch of you live
in the area and others of you that are
in Florida or southeast United States
and people are coming down and are
helping and it's really great and again
you can text disaster to 2022 or go to
volunteer florida.org I will definitely
volunteer on the ground at some point
maybe I'm thinking maybe around
Thanksgiving I could take a couple days
off and we'll we'll go maybe I can you
guys come in with me we'll go build
something we're gonna go build I got all
thumbs up at the same time uh we'll go
build something that'll be that'll be
pretty great so anyway this also gave me
an idea we found this other clip you may
remember a couple weeks ago
we played a clip of Jordan Peterson
talking about the necessity of men in
society that what would societies do
without men and you know I was thinking
as Governor DeSantis was talking about
the volunteers it's like we need men we
need women we need adults we need
competent people I don't care if you're
a male or a female I don't care if
you're black or you're white I don't
care if you're gay or straight it's like
if you know how to do something right
now whether that's dig a hole so that
they can put a new line in whether
that's do some electrical work whether
that's just help feed elderly people
whatever it is we need people right now
but a lot of the hardest work we know
simply will be done by men it's just how
it is and we showed you a video a couple
weeks ago of Jordan giving this great
talk about that and on the side of it it
was a split screen and on the side was
this guy working in a sewer with
cockroaches all over him and it's like
these are these are the people that the
left these days would tell you or this
is a white privileged guy with the worst
sort of job known to man we found
another one of these and I just thought
it was perfectly appropriate to show you
right now it's okay to be a man it's not
okay it's necessary
what the hell are we gonna do without
men
you look around the city here you see
all these buildings go up these men
they're doing impossible things they're
under the streets working on the sewers
they're up on the power lines and the
storms and the rain they're keeping this
impossible infrastructure functioning
this thing that works and in miraculous
manner they work themselves
to death
and now often literally the gratitude
for that is sorely lacking especially
among the people who should be most
grateful you see University professors
especially of the social justice bent
they take everything they have for
granted failing to understand entirely
that there's a massive infrastructure of
unbelievably hard-working
solidly laboring working-class men
breaking themselves in half on a regular
basis making sure that everything that
always breaks works
we need people I know he's talking about
men right there but they'll obviously
there'll be women too we just need
people that can do work and that want to
do the work that nobody wants to do and
that's what we're going to get to here
and I'm not kidding I'm going to take my
guys we're going to go we're going to go
rebuild some stuff uh when the time
comes you know the bridge does not exist
on Sanibel right now so I'm assuming
that they'll have a ferry service over
the next couple months obviously
rebuilding a massive Causeway I don't
know how long the causeway I think the
causeway is at least a mile long I don't
know how long it'll take to build that I
do suspect that if we wanted to send the
Army Corps of Engineers here and if we
took some of that Ukraine money to fund
that we could probably have it done in
like two months but unfortunately that's
not really the way the federal
government works but I know that
everyone in Florida is going to do
everything that they possibly can okay a
couple comments from the locals
Community uh EK says I don't think
Kamala knows what she's going to say
before she opens her mouth she just
starts to talk and sees where the
sentence takes her yes I I'm always
saying that about her that it's just
like she's going and going and going and
it's not like Biden where when Biden is
talking you know he's losing the thing
from the beginning right like he has the
original idea right they ask him a
question he starts saying something and
then he just forgets then he mumbles it
out or you know he uses one of his reset
phrases and and that unfortunately is
one of the symptoms of some level of
cognitive decline it just is with Kamala
I don't think she has cognitive decline
I don't I just don't think her cognitive
capabilities are that great so she just
starts talking and she thinks that if
she just puts a lot of words in a
sentence that that makes the sentence
valuable it's just incredible watching
this woman speak it is just terrible
which is perfect segue to the next
comment uh Alan says why is Harris like
a bad kindergarten teacher she talks to
everybody like their children and isn't
that in stark contrast that's why we
want to do the show the way we did today
it's in such stark contrast of the way
Ron DeSantis and Casey DeSantis and all
of the the people here the entire
apparatus of the state here in Florida
they talk to people like they're adults
hey we've got work to do we need people
here's how you can volunteer here's how
you can help when the media goes after
DeSantis that clip we showed you
yesterday and he was like look I know
you guys want to politicize everything
but you think you're attacking me you're
not attacking me you're attacking all
these people who are doing their hard
work everything that could possibly be
done to fix this state is being done
right now this is it it does not mean
it's perfect you know this is what
people want all the time and the media
always wants this like perfect thing
it's what the flaw of the leftists and
the Socialists are they think if you
just if you build a system that in their
minds is perfect that it'll always be
perfect but perfect systems don't exist
because you know what has to exist
within those perfect systems humans and
you know what humans are not perfect we
are the flaw in the system this is a
problem have you ever seen The Matrix
watch it so the point is we are doing
everything we possibly can here and we
we just unfortunately have a
administration at a federal level that
is is incompetent whether it comes to
doing what's right domestically or
internationally I really do hope they do
what's right uh when it comes to Florida
obviously
and by the way if there was an absolute
natural disaster something really
horrific that happened whether it was a
fire or a hurricane well they don't get
hurricanes in California but whether it
was a fire or an earthquake or whatever
it might be in California I would want
the government to be as effective and
competent and everything else even
though I fled the state it has nothing
to do with my feelings about the
political apparatus of the state it has
nothing to do with my feelings about
Gavin Newsom you know it's like if we
are to be the United States of America
then if something bad happens in Cali we
got to help and if something bad happens
in Florida we got help uh mad says Biden
approves the pipeline and then blows it
up just like giving 40 million to fight
against deporting illegal aliens yeah
it's like look I don't know what
happened okay I don't know what happened
but something feels very very weird
about this would Russia blow up their
own pipeline to Germany where they get
tons and tons of money as I said as the
winter is coming so they know they're
going to get more and more because
people need to heat their homes Etc
they're about to get all this money
they're obviously putting them ton of
money into the war effort did they blow
up their own Pipeline and then we see
these videos of Tony blinken and of Joe
Biden basically saying hey if Russia
moves into Ukraine Nordstrom will be no
more and now nordstream in effect is no
more
what's going on here like and this also
is where you got to give the devil is
due I know that most of you watching
this right now and conventional wisdom
would be that there's going to be this
massive Red Wave but I have said all
along about giving the devil is due and
it's like could right before the
election covid II monkey pox 9 nuclear
war like anything I don't mean that to
be like crazy alarmist I mean it just
like
everything is in flux right now
everything is in flux so if if Biden's
looking at the numbers and it's not
Biden looking if whoever's in charge is
looking at the numbers they're going man
we are going to be crushed in these
elections what what could we do to make
sure that doesn't happen well a war
helps a war does help it's just how it
is a war helps an incumbent party
because people start getting behind the
president during times of War so did we
just escalate this thing I don't know
and if you have anyone that you think
can give me some better analysis on this
uh let's get him on the show and let's
talk it out uh guys as always uh
subscribe if you have not at rumble.com
Reuben report if you want to play along
during the show in live chat you can
join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and we have a
cold close with election denier and
possible murderer Hillary Clinton see ya
on Monday I remember as a as a young
student you know trying to figure out
how did people get basically
um drawn in by Hitler how did that
happen and I'd watch newsreels and I'd
see this guy standing up there ranting
and raving and people shouting and
raising their arms I said what's
happened to these people why did they
believe that
I think it was difficult for
most Americans to believe that this guy
would be as dangerous as he turned out
to be and it's no longer just the whiff
of violence but the appeals to violence
look at immigration they don't want to
get together and try to resolve this uh
issue they don't want to try to figure
out how we have secure borders because
they'd rather have an issue than a
solution this is an attack on freedom on
Democracy on Truth this is an attack
that has Ripple effects for all of us
the threats to democracy are real and
the only way to defeat them is showing
up and voting